I'm actually you're just gonna take a
step back clear out some of this stuff
you you've understood the first half of
how this process of atherosclerosis
happens and we're gonna finish off the
second half so all of the action is
still gonna happen in the Tunica intima
so that much is gonna stay the same and
so far we talked about macrophages and
we talked about how they form foam cells
and they they eat up all the fat then
they form this kind of lake of fat and
so let me let me leave it there so
that's where the picture is at so far
and now let's talk about what happens
after that so the next step step five is
basically what happens is the smooth
muscle cells smooth muscle cells we
haven't talked about them so far smooth
muscle cells they shimmy or they dance
over let's write dance over to Tunica
intima so really again everything is
happening in the Tunica intima right you
can see that that's where all the action
is and so when I say they danced over
them I'm being a little bit silly but
basically what happens is that these
cells these red smooth muscle cells
these are the smooth muscle cells smooth
muscle they are gonna start migrating
they're gonna start migrating or moving
and they're gonna start migrating into
this space maybe that one will go over
there maybe this one will go over here
perhaps this one and the way these two
are kind of migrating is that you know
there's a lot of action going on the
macrophages are there they've got the
LDL in that lake of fat and a lot of
chemicals are being released by these
cells and so they sense that something's
happening so they kind of move over
there and what they begin to do is make
a fibrous cap that's step six so they
make a fibrous cap actually the meat let
me write who makes it so it's very clear
smooth muscle cells SMC
smooth muscle cells make a fibrous cap
and what a fibrous cap is is think about
when you're really young and you're
playing and you know you didn't really
pay attention and fell a lot you might
have come home with skinned knees and
and I certainly did my mom used to
always remark on that and those skinned
knees turn into scabs right and so these
smooth muscle cells these fibers caps
basically think of it as a scab a scab
that forms over this lake of fat so I've
been drawing for you this yellow lake of
fat and now these smooth muscle cells
they come in and say well you know we've
got a we've got to make a cap over this
thing me erase again and draw for you
what that might look like so let's say
that this lake is getting bigger this
lake over time has gotten really quite
big and you've got more fat in here from
all that LDL that keeps depositing
because going backwards the endothelial
cells are not working well and so you've
got this kind of weird set of
endothelium kind of around it and the
smooth muscle cells come over and they
decide they're gonna help with making a
fibrous cap so let me do that in a new
color let's choose let's do it in red I
guess that would come up nicely so they
basically make this cap here and this
cap kind of mixes in to this layer and
settles in right there right and you've
got some endothelium over it but
sometimes you don't and so this layer of
endothelium is pretty well disrupted I
would say you've got this nice thick
fibrous cap and what's in that cap is
things like collagen or elastin so
proteins are in this cap so you've got a
fibrous cap and it's made of collagen
and elastin
so these are the proteins that we know
help with keeping all of the cells in
our body in place and so you can always
point to your bones or your nose and and
you can find these proteins there so it
makes this fibrous cap and so now really
what you have is fat with a cap right so
that's that's kind of how I think of
this this is fat with a cap and it
sounds simple and in a way that's that's
a very reasonable way to think of it
you've got the lake of fat and over it
you've got this fibrous cap and what
that does is two things you've already
seen that this is kind of starting to
bulge into the blood vessel right so we
have this I'm gonna go to that little
diagram in the corner again so you had a
beautiful blood vessel nice and kind of
circular and then now you've got this
you know a fat that's sitting in here
right and over it is giant Lake right
and over it I put a cap so now you've
got a cap here so what has happened to
this blood vessel well you know you had
a certain radius on that blood vessel
and that radius has gotten smaller so in
terms of like kind of big big key ideas
he changes your blood vessel has
actually gotten smaller right so one is
a smaller radius and you can see that in
the picture right smaller radius and we
know that radius is related to
resistance that means increased
resistance increased resistance here to
blood flow and of course I'm talking
about the distance from here over to
here is smaller now that you've got
something pushing out into the into the
lumen and the other change and this is
actually quite interesting is that the
wall itself is actually tougher it's
more stiff and so right here one of the
other things actually I didn't talk
about too much but maybe I should say
very quickly right now
maybe even a step 7 is that the smooth
muscle cells make or let's say here lay
down calcium so when I say lay down what
does that mean exactly well what are
they like bricklayers but when I say lay
down calcium what I mean is that these
cells are actually gonna start
pretending in a way that they are making
bone and actually the dead foam cells
create this little micro environment
where these smooth muscles start
thinking oh my gosh maybe I should lay
down some calcium put some calcium here
so they'll put a little calcium nugget
right here I'll put another calcium
nugget right there
they'll put another calcium nugget there
and there and all sudden if you start
looking you start thinking oh wow this
is actually very calcified and this is
actually looking a little bit like bone
this is this is what happens with bone
so they start calcifying this entire
area and if you calcify this area if you
start putting down these little crystals
of calcium then what's going to happen
is that your your arteries literally
become crispy crunchy which it which
sounds kind of disgusting and I guess it
is but they're essentially more stiff
and that's really the key point is that
you get more stiffness or lower
compliance so lower compliance and that
goes back to the crunchiness of the of
the vessel or the inability to be kind
of flexible so lower compliance less
flexible this is a little reminder of
what that means so those are the big
changes that you see and the lower
radius increases resistance and the
lower compliance means that it's harder
for these large and middle sized
arteries to expand like a balloon every
time the blood pulses through so
both those things are gonna cause
increase in your blood pressure